our next guest is an Emmy winner her
name is Kira Sedgwick she's been acting
since she was 12. and now she's making a
big debut behind the camera the new
movie Space Oddity is her directorial
debut for a major feature film thank you
very much the stories include Somebody
by the name of Kevin Bacon the movie who
just happens to be married to the
director the movie is about a young man
called Alex whose lifelong dream comes
true when he's picked to help colonize
Mars in this preview Alex's dad that's
played by Kevin Bacon doesn't approve of
his son's plans and talks about the
future of the family farm here's a look
not so on
it'll go to a developer and if we
continue down that path there'll be no
Farms left not to import even more from
halfway around the globe
nonetheless we
we gotta hold on to our Farms
this is our spot
it's our little corner of the world
and I'm not giving it up
and I'm not giving it up Kyra Sedgwick
bravo bravo bravo to you making your
major film debut so much can I say you
knocked it out of the park knocked it
out of the park but of all this is not
your first time directing but this is
your first time directing a major film
and all the projects you could choose
why was this one why did this one speak
to you because you've been working on it
for quite some time yeah I feel like it
has everything you know I feel like it
has the funny it has the sad and it has
the hopeful yeah and it has the romance
yes and you know it really takes you to
all these emotional places and then at
the end you feel hopeful and good about
being here on Earth and I think that
that's you know a really important
message especially right now and it's
interesting I always love it when
husband and wives work together I'm
always fascinated by that Dynamic you're
the director which means you're in
charge so I'm wondering does Kevin Bacon
take notes very well and if he does what
was the note you gave him and how did he
receive said no
he's great at taking notes I mean he's a
brilliant actor and and this is a great
part for him because it's something he
hasn't really done before you know I
think I'm a very exacting director and I
have a I have a picture in my head of
what I want it to be there was this one
line and it was the it was the letters
okay and it kind of took a while for him
to get there and I kept like hammering
him with this one thing and after a
while he was like I just don't know what
you want from me but he got it he nailed
it well I mean he's growing he's a great
actor but I mean according to what I'm
reading here he was not your first
choice to play Alex's that's right
that's right how many people did you
call before you know only one and the
truth is like in independent movies
people come people go like schedules
change but you know but he read it and
said I would like to do this oh no
response when you asked oh he said what
took you so long I don't know why you
waited until now he was tossing and
turning every night he's like I can do
that okay line so you say that directing
is your true calling not acting yeah why
would you say that when you're such a
good actor I think you have to take that
back because I read that too Nate where
you said you know after this I think I
want to concentrate on directing what if
the audience says no cure we don't want
you to do it but I was curious like Nate
why you why you think that way now well
I can always act and Direct in the same
state I mean I think that you know
there's some you're just a much bigger
part of the storytelling as the Director
I think as an actor you're always a
pretty small part of the whole piece and
as director you have to be you have to
have the whole piece in your head and
there's something super exciting about
that it uses all your faculties you know
yes great I was fascinated too by the
premise of this young and you have to
see the movie to see the dynamic why he
wanted to go to Mars and I love the Love
Story between him and the love I thought
she was great Alexander oh she was
fantastic yeah but the fact that he
wanted to go to Mars was that something
that appealed to you is are you
fascinated with Mars do you want to go
to Mars I definitely don't
and to me you know Mars is really a
symbol of this idea that there's a
Planet B yes or a plan B that we can go
to and there isn't you know what I mean
and I think that the the wonderful thing
about this movie is that the the
messages you know we have to fight the
good fight here even though people die
even though we have climate issues even
though there's loss and there's
difficulties in fear we have to fight
the good fight here and and it's worth
it right a lot of work to do here the
grass isn't always green we have to
water our grass there's no grass on Mars
uninhabitable it's fun watching you and
Kevin together I saw the latest video
where you guys are singing Miley Cyrus
as flowers yes how does that come about
the two of you it would be fun to do
it's him it's all him what do you mean
he plans it he he knows what song to do
he's got his finger on the pulse of the
pop culture of the pop culture which I
don't and uh no it's amazing I mean he's
like honey let's do this thing and I'm
like sure you know I think it's joyful
it's celebratory and I really like doing
it we usually are making fun of
ourselves too I think there's a lot of
fun at your house and we have to point
out your son is involved in this movie
too let's give a shout out that's right
that's right Travis did the music there
you go yes daughter's an actress it's a
family business Family Affair yep yep
what is the best bit of advice you've
given them
about the industry given them about the
industry trust your instincts you've got
this yeah yeah and you know how hard it
is I mean they know how hard it is so
that's that's like a gift and also a
curse it's both they've got two great
role models in that that's right never a
bad thing that's right congratulations
thank you so much thank you appreciate
it Kyra Cedric the name of the movie is
called Space Odyssey Space Oddity not
Odyssey Space Oddity let me get that
right it's in theaters where you got to
see it on the big screen that's right
it's always better to watch a movie on
the big screen in my humble opinion in
the movie is out of this world